bueno un corredor aéreo buenas tardes
consiste básicamente una zona de
exclusión aérea consiste en prohibir el
tráfico aéreo militar no solamente aéreo
sobre un territorio determinado ya ha
sido usado por la otan en otras
ocasiones sobre todo en las guerras de
los balcanes
en este caso no es una opción viable
para la otan porque implicaría es
esencialmente tener que derribar
cualquier avión de la fuerza aérea rusa
esto equivaldría
eventualmente a una a una escalada de
hostilidades que no es aceptable ni por
la otan ni por la federación rusa los
únicos que claman por el establecimiento
de este tipo de medida es probablemente
el gobierno de ucrania pero no es algo
que esté siendo considerado por ninguna
de las partes
claro volviendo la mirada al alto el
fuego porque se había acordado un alto
el fuego concretamente en ciudades como
mariupol igual no vaya y no en el resto
de ciudades del país
bueno mariupol y volver y cuando vaya
están sitiadas por el este y por el
oeste son importantes tanto para el
ejército ruso como para el ucraniano por
lass por es el corazón industrial de
ucrania corazón educativo y tecnológico
además el puerto es fundamental para
poder establecer un corredor en toda la
costa ucraniana tomada por la federación
rusa y las fuerzas separatistas de los
brazos de donges
porque evacuar a los civiles para
minimizar el daño colateral para llevar
a una rendición no es lo mismo atacar
una ciudad con civiles que sin ella el
tipo de operaciones puede ser más
intenso cuando solamente fuerzas
militares adentro
aparentemente no logró
concretarse tanto la federación rusa
como el gobierno ucraniano claman que la
otra parte violó los términos del
corredor verde que llevaría a sap orilla
que al noroeste es probable que las dos
cosas se hayan dado a la vez que ambos
lados hayan intentado tomar algún tipo
de ventaja de la situación
y sra señor argüello precisamente ha
hablado de esto de las acusaciones
mutuas también serguéi lávrov como hemos
dicho ya en este informativo duda de las
intenciones de diálogo de celine skip
brevemente como interpreta estas
acusaciones
creo que ninguno de los dos
bandos en este enfrentamiento tiene
ningún tipo de confianza en la no
solamente en las intenciones sino en la
honestidad del otro
hay una completa oposición de
percepciones de la guerra
diplomáticamente no hay ningún tipo de
punto en común con lo cual es natural
que cada uno contradiga lo que dice el
otro
con
completamente no hay ningún punto común
se acusan mutuamente de genocidio se
acusan mutuamente de atrocidades contra
civiles
por lo cual salvo las negociaciones que
se estén dando en minsk van a seguir
acusando se
completamente